[Musique]
ce soir nous allons vous parler de
l'école nous allons vous parler de
l'école d'aujourd'hui et d'une école
pour aujourd'hui
on a chacun un pied dans le milieu de
l'éducation nationale et comme vous le
savez dans les écoles chaque jour à
chaque instant on est confronté aux
difficultés d apprentissage scolaire
d'où viennent ces difficultés est-ce
qu'elles viennent des enfants et bien
quand on regarde le film documentaire
est ré devenir de clara bénard on voit
que des enfants qui ne sont qui ne vont
pas à l'école
après naturellement et sans difficulté
alors si le problème ne vient pas des
enfants d'où vient-il
il ya quelques temps nous avons
découvert l'existence des écoles
démocratique dans ces écoles le cadre
est totalement différent de celui des
écoles traditionnelles
tout d'abord les relations entre les
enfants et les adultes ne sont pas
hiérarchiser
chacun est considérée sur un même pied
d'égalité ensuite la gestion de l'école
et démocratique c'est à dire que chaque
jour la gestion d'écoles et le
fonctionnement de l'école est décidé par
l'ensemble de ses membres enfants comme
adultes les décisions les règles sont
discutées et votées par tous sur le
principe suivant une personne égale une
voix
ces écoles accueillent des enfants de 4
à 19 ans il n'y a pas de 30 tranche
d'âge tout le monde est ensemble
il n'y a pas non plus d'emploi du temps
ni programme
chacun fait ce qu'il veut de ces
journées est bien dans ses écoles les
enfants apprennent et ils apprennent
sans difficulté il semblerait donc que
ce qui pose problème dans les
apprentissages ce soit le programme et
le et le cadre dans lequel il s'inscrit
et c'est ce qu'on va développer
qu'est ce qu'un programme
c'est un ensemble de connaissances et de
savoir qu'il faut apprendre à un âge
donné et dans un temps défini mais vous
le savez tous comme moi tous les enfants
sont différents et tous les enfants sont
pas égaux devant cette tâche à accomplir
pour 2007
40% des élèves de cm2 sont sortis avec
de graves lacunes plus deux cent mille
d'entre eux ont acquis des acquis
fragiles et plus de 100000 n'ont pas eu
la maîtrise des compétences de base
comme toute la la vie de l'enfant tourne
autour de l'école et bien cet échec
relatif de ne pas savoir à un moment
donné devient vite un échec personnel à
cause notamment toutes les sanctions qui
qui existe et l'enfant perd confiance en
lui rentrer dans une spirale de
dévalorisation de démotivation voire de
décrocheurs pour l'année 2010 7,80 mille
jeunes sont sortis du système scolaire
sans diplôme soit deux fois la
population de valenciennes alors une
solution à ce problème qui est important
comme le dit einstein pour trouver la
solution et non pas une réponse mais la
solution à un problème il faudrait
peut-être avoir un autre regard sur ce
problème lui nous dit qu'il faut changer
le niveau de penser on ne peut pas
résoudre un problème on ne peut pas
résoudre un problème avec le même niveau
de penser que celui qui l'a créé or
l'institution propose comme solution est
bien des dispositifs pédagogiques
mais qui dit pédagogie c'est la
pédagogie et en l'ensemble des
subterfuges pour faire apprendre un
programme et donc vous voyez qu'on est
toujours sur le même niveau de penser et
ce qui rend les dispositifs pour le
moins inefficaces et très coûteux
ainsi un enfant décrocheur coûte à la
collectivité 230000 euros
au cours de sa vie au saut au cours de
sa vie et quant aux résultats
eh bien je fais référence au rapport de
2016 du la seine escaut lé comité
national d'évaluation des systèmes
scolaires
qui constate que les trente dernières
années de politiques éducatives pour
réduire les inégalités ont été plus qu
inefficace
elles ont été contreproductives alors
d'où vient cette contre-productivité
bien einstein peut l'expliquer c'est à
dire qu'on est resté sur le même niveau
de penser ivan illitch dans les années
soixante dix aurait pu aussi donner la
réponse
ivan illitch est un penseur et un
critique et des sociétés industrielles
yvan niniches nous dit qu'à partir du
moment où dans une société
et bien cette société institut ciani
zain moyens il arrive à un moment donc
afin d'atteindre abus dont de résoudre
un problème est bien ce moyen tend à
croître jusqu'à dépasser un seuil où à
ce moment là il devient dysfonctionnel
et une nuits au but qui n'est sensible
servir il donne quelques exemples celui
de l'automobile ainsi l'automobile va
nuire aux transports on sait que les
problèmes que posent d'automobiles
aujourd'hui est de la même manière dans
une autre dans un autre domaine l'école
va nuire à l'éducation comme la médecine
va nuire à la santé
et l'institution devient
contre-productive en plus d'aliéner
l'être humain et la société dans son
ensemble et de cette agression j'en
parlerai enfin à la fin de mon propos
l'échec scolaire n'est donc pas l'échec
des élèves il n'est que l'échec d'un
dispositif qui veut faire apprendre à
programmer qu'il n'y arrive pas et il
devient contreproductif dans la mesure
est bien où il laisse une frange de la
population dont il se dit avoir la
responsabilité sur le côté il y a des
conséquences à l'école du programme
devrais je dire parce que on n'apprend
pas on n'apprend pas que les savoie on
apprend plein de choses qui sont
inconscientes et implicites et ça il
faut vraiment en être
cette fois-ci conscient et bien quand
les enfants entrent à l'école du
programme eh bien ils doivent apprendre
ce programme et cette acquisition ne
peut se faire que par la contrainte
un enfant qui entre à l'école du
programme doit obéir
vieillir c'est un devoir pour lui et en
même temps qu'il obéit pour apprendre il
apprend à obéir et quand il désobéit ou
quand il ne fait pas ce qu'on lui dit et
bien il devient ou paresseux ou déviants
ou contractent des maladies des dix
quelque chose quand il entre à l'école
du programme est bien l'enfant apprend à
dépendre de quelqu'un d'autre
autrement dit il apprend qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui a pensé pour lui qui ne le
connaît pas qui lui a pas demandé son
avis mais qui sait ce qui est bon pour
lui et propose des activités dans ce
sens et donc l'enfant n'apprend apprend
à ne plus agir pour lui-même ni par soi
même ce qui va à l'encontre eux mêmes du
principe d'autonomie autonomie qui est
un objectif principal dans toute
l'éducation les savoirs sont dispensés
sur le même niveau on apprend les faits
d'économie d'histoire de géographie
comme a plus un égale 2 autrement dit
comme des vérités non contestable et ses
vérités sont d'autant moins contestable
qu'elle permette d'acquérir un diplôme
voir un métier et elles sont d'autant
moins contesté qu'elle participe à votre
identité professionnelle
on apprend donc que la pensée d'autrui
et bien puisse faire autorité et du coup
on apprend plus à penser pour soi même
et par soi même et ceux qui pensent par
eux-mêmes et pour eux-mêmes et bien en
général sont au qualifié de marginaux
non pas l'avis de tout le monde
et il faut des catastrophes sanitaires
économiques pour se rendre compte que ce
qu'on vous a dit à un moment donné et
bien c'est pas exactement la vérité moi
je pense souvent comme exemple à
fukushima il et les ingénieurs japonais
qui sont bardés de diplômes qu'ils
savaient des tas de choses quoi on était
capable de mettre des centrales
nucléaires sur des failles sismiques
le programme est bien sert en fait une
idéologie quelle est cette idéologie est
bien l'idéologie c'est une conception
classique qu'on a et en particulier pour
l'enfant dans la conception classique de
l'enfant l'enfant c'est un être immature
un être fragile un être incomplets à
naître à qui on ne fait pas confiance on
ne donne pas de responsabilité l'enfant
doit donc obéir et doit se soumettre
pour acquérir une éducation mais cette
conception cette idéologie c'est
purement et simplement un héritage de la
société féodale
donc on a vu que et bien l'école du
programme ne peut garantir la réussite
de tous de par sa structure il ya des
effets structurels et des effets des
causes plutôt idéologique à cause de
l'enseignement du programme les enfants
ne peuvent pas développer leur propre
potentiel qui est la condition une
condition importante pour
l'épanouissement personnel et à son
corps défendant
l'école du programme est bien développe
chez les individus une pensée qui ne
favorise pas l'autonomie et qui ne
permet pas de remettre en cause ce qui
est acquis et les sociologues comme
bourdieu et stable est au bord de l'eau
on dit qu'en fait voilà c'est ce qui
permet au système de se reproduire
bien qu'on en soit bien qu'on soit
conscient
que ce système et dysfonctionnements
alors comment apprendre sans programme
eh bien c'est ce que font les hommes
depuis la nuit des temps et c'est ce que
développe peter gray dans son livre
libre pour apprendre peter gray et
psychologue et professeur de psychologie
à l'université de boston et dans la
première partie de son livre il nous
parle du mode de vie des chasseurs
cueilleurs des tribus nomades
en fait ce mode de vie est calqué sur
celui nos ancêtres avant la
sédentarisation le développement de
l'agriculture et celui des villes et ce
qui est important d'observer c'est
justement le rôle que jouent les adultes
dans l'éducation des enfants et comment
les enfants apprennent alors les adultes
chez les chasseurs cueilleurs ont
confiance dans le fait que de permettre
à des enfants de faire ce qu'ils veulent
vont leur vont leur permettre justement
d'apprendre ce qu'ils ont besoin
d'apprendre dans le monde dans lequel
ils vivent les enfants sont libres ils
ne vont pas à l'école n'ont pas d'emploi
du temps prédéfini
ils passent leur temps tous ensemble
tous âges confondus ils font et ils font
absolument ce qu'ils veulent de leur
journée les adultes ne dirige pas
l'éducation des enfants
ce sont les enfants qui s'auto éduque
alors comment ça se passait bien les
enfants ont la liberté d'observer tout
ce que font les adultes et de participer
à leur activité comme ils en ont envie
les adultes de leur côté participe au
processus d'auto apprentissage des
enfants en répondant à leurs
sollicitations
les adultes ne surveille pas les progrès
que font les enfants mines les félicite
en fait chez les chasseurs cueilleurs il
n'y a pas de jugement il n'y a pas de
violence c'est une façon de vivre et
chez les enfants du coup il y en a pas
non plus et chez les enfants l'activité
principale c'est le jeu libre le jeu
sans l'intervention des adultes et dans
leur jeu et limite les adultes ils
jouent à chasser à fabriquer des outils
et à construire des huttes à
sélectionner les différentes variétés de
plantes etc etc
et c'est comme ça que les enfants
naturellement se prépare à devenir des
adultes accomplis et adaptés à leur
milieu
et tout cela ce qui est important de
souligner un c'est que tout cela ils le
font parce qu'ils en ont envie encore
une fois personne ne leur demande de
faire personne n'est dupe
les enfants ils s'auto éduque alors
est-ce que des enfants libres apprennent
et bien la réponse est évidente
bien sûr que oui pourquoi crois tu ont
aujourd'hui que c'est faux où alors eh
bien nous croyons ça parce que nous
avons perdu notre liberté et notre
liberté d'apprendre naturellement
librement comme le dit peter gray
apprendre fait partie de nos gènes
autrement dit on ne peut pas ne pas
apprendre réfléchissez comment avez-vous
appris à marcher ou à parler est ce que
quelqu'un vous a soufflé des mots pour
que vous les répétiez est ce qu'on vous
a expliqué qu'il fallait poser un pied
devant l'autre
est ce qu'on voulait enseigner bien sûr
que non tout ça vous l'avez appris
naturellement et bien de même que les
enfants des chasseurs cueilleurs on a
pris naturellement à devenir des adultes
accomplis et adaptés à leur milieu
nos enfants si on leur en laisse la
liberté vont devenir des adultes
accomplis et adaptés à leur milieu
je vais prendre l'exemple de la lecture
l'écrit est présente partout dans notre
société
de ce fait il est inévitable d'apprendre
à lire et de même que les enfants ont
appris naturellement à parler parce que
parler est un besoin pour interagir dans
notre monde
ils apprendront à lire à écrire et à
compter parce que ça aussi c'est un
besoin pour interagir dans notre monde
on l'a vu on le sait des enfants libres
après naturellement ce qu'ils ont besoin
d'apprendre dans le monde dans lequel
ils vivent les enfants des écoles
démocratiques sont libres et ils savent
tous lire laura poitras a été dans une
école démocratique et elle elle a appris
à lire à 13 ans oui ça ne l'a pas
empêché de devenir réalisatrice et
productrice de films documentaires
journalistes et photographes rien que ça
et en 2015
elle a reçu l'oscar du meilleur film
documentaire pour son citizen fort peu
importe l'âge à laquelle l'enfant
apprendra à lire
il apprendra à lire il le fera avec
d'autant plus de facilité qu'il le fera
lui même au moment qui sera le sien il
le fera aussi sans contrainte et selon
sa propre méthodologie sans manuels
scolaires comme pour la marche
l'auto apprentissage est un acte naturel
on pourrait presque dire que c'est un
acte physiologique alors on l'a vu
l'enfant a besoin qu'on lui fasse
confiance et il a besoin de liberté pour
apprendre il a aussi besoin de jouer
librement sans l'intervention de
l'adulte pour se construire parce que
jouer c'est son métier c'est sa vie un
enfant privé de sa liberté ne peut pas
s'épanouir un enfant qui ne peut pas se
développer naturel et qui ne peut pas
vivre sa vie est un enfant qui souffre
en silence ou qui explosent les enfants
subissent de nombreuses violences la
violence de devoir rester assis la
violence de devoir faire ce qu'on leur
demande de faire
la violence de devoir réussir à le faire
ils subissent aussi la violence des
jugements s'il n'y arrive pas s'ils
n'ont pas envie de faire ça ou qui ne
comprennent même pas ce qu'on leur
demande
et toute cette violence là vivent en
silence parce qu'ils sont les seuls à
savoir qu'elles subissent des violences
aux yeux des adultes tout ça c'est la
normalité pour la plupart des adultes
il n'y a pas de violences dans tout ça
parce que c'est une façon de vivre
l'auto éducation fonctionne et permet
vraiment à l'enfant d'apprendre de se
construire et de s'épanouir l'école
démocratique de la salle baril valait en
attestent elle a près de 50 ans
d'existence et elle a fait ses preuves
c'est un professeur émérite et reconnu
de
la prestigieuse université de columbia
qui a fondé cette école avec une équipe
il a fait des constats comme voilà
comment en tant qu'enseignants et il
s'est posé beaucoup de questions sur
l'éducation est en fait il à repenser le
modèle éducatif en ces termes ou un
modèle éducatif où l'individu est bien
développera ses propres représentations
de ce qu'il a envie de comprendre et
d'utiliser tous les moyens qu'ils jugent
nécessaires à cette compréhension dans
les écoles démocratique
on l'avait dit on dans l'introduction il
y a deux piliers essentiels
c'est à dire les apprentissages autonome
et la gestion démocratique de l'école
c'est cette école à 50 ans et continue
de fonctionner quel est le
retentissement de cette école en europe
et bien en 2008 une association a vu le
jour le dec qui fédère toutes les écoles
démocratique d'europe
voici la carte des écoles des
principales écoles démocratique en
europe et pour la france est bien en
2014 s'est ouverte la première école
démocratique à dijon ce sont les bus le
rouge qui sont les créations et en
violet les projets et on voit
l'engouement pour ce type d'école les
écoles démocratique apporte une
alternative à un modèle et un modèle
éducatif
que sont devenus les enfants de l'asbl
ballet school pourrait se poser la
question revient sur plus de 40 ans
d'existence et bien 80 % d'entre eux ont
suivi des études supérieures et ont eu
leur premier choix d'université parmi
les plus prestigieuses 20% d'entre eux
ont embrassé des carrières artistiques
ou artisanales et la plupart d'entre eux
ont appris à lire à l'âge de plus de dix
ans parce que l'auto éducation
fonctionne parce que les apprentissages
autonome rendent à l'enfant la
responsabilité de sa vie parce que la
gestion démocratique d'une école prépare
l'enfant à devenir un citoyen actif et
responsable
et parce que nous sommes le changement
que nous voulons pour le monde
nous avons décidé de
créer une école démocratique à
condé-sur-l'escaut l'école de lettres et
du devenir et elle ouvrira ses portes en
septembre 2018
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]